I be the world divides there there many
artificial and perhaps even a few
natural ways of dividing people in the
world but one way to differentiate
people art is is if you like the the
people who do a certain thing and don't
have enormous curiosity about the things
they don't do and those who are curious
about everything uh one version of that
of course if you want to put it in terms
of the history of ideas is as I Berlin's
distinction between the Hedgehog and the
Fox which using the a fragment of our
Killa cos he says the hawk the hedgehog
does many things but the Fox knows one
big big implicit my mother was very much
someone who was interested everything
and whose curiosity didn't abate with
the years I mean many appetites abate
with age and that but in our case
curiosity avidity for intellectual and
cultural and aesthetic and sensual
experience didn't didn't diminish Isaac
bob all the great russian short story
writers said you must know everything I
think my mother
I believe I say this in the book in
swimming in the sea of death that my
mother was was very much of that view
and that didn't change and you could
argue I think that if you if you're
interested in everything if you're
curious about everything it's a lot
harder to die
I think that I felt very strongly it was
her death
and that everyone has if they're lucky
enough the right to die the death they
want to die lots of people don't have
that luck and so if she wanted to bull
in the idea that she would beat the odds
once more as she done twice in the past
with cancer it wasn't for me to stand in
the way of that or to gainsay to use a
no verb that I was I I was there to help
that's the way I construed my role what
I thought was irrelevant in the instance
of course it's relevant now that it's
she's dead and all these things have
taken place but at the time I just
thought I'm there to support her and if
I can be of help
whatever I may think privately what I
think probably isn't all that important
one way